أمي فلسطينية وأبي بريطاني في
7 أكتوبر أه قصفت قنبلة تابعة للجيش الإسرائيلي
منزلهم وذهبوا إلى
كنيستهم المحلية كانوا فلسطينيين مسيحيين وهم
هناك منذ أن أصبح هناك
100 شخص الآن في تلك الكنيسة ونحن
نشعر بقلق عميق  من أجل سلامتهم،
أعني أن الـ 2448 ساعة التي
انقطع فيها الإنترنت وكل شيء آخر
كانت مؤلمة، أعني عدم معرفة ما إذا
كانوا أحياء أم أمواتًا، فنحن قلقون
عليهم على أي حال ولا أستطيع أن أخبركم بما
فعله ذلك بنا.  كعائلة، لا يمكنهم
التحرك، هناك قصف في الجنوب،
كان هناك قصف على ما يسمى بالطريق الآمن
الذي تم منحهم إياه للوصول إلى الجنوب.
لم يعد هناك مكان آمن في غزة ولم يعد
الناس يقولون إلى أين نذهب لنكون آمنين
السؤال الذي يطرحونه الآن هو
أين نريد أن نكون عندما
نموت